he's one of the stars of uncle drew
great to have him back on be a five-time
all-star Chris Webber NBA on TNT analyst
see web how you feeling did you
Debbie read any movie reviews no I don't
think I will be the community not always
kind of trying to watch the audience and
get a feel for them and I did take my
nephew's to see the movie who would do
the brutally honest and so their reviews
I kind of enjoyed and I even though
their kids and they like silly stuff as
long as they liked it that's why I want
to know about us you know whether it was
good or not
no surprised were you that Kevin Durant
was there for the premiere but he wasn't
in the movie he's a basketball fan he's
like a bastard chunky he's like one of
the best players in the world but I'll
go to like an eighth grade basketball
game and a show from here it's funny and
at the end I was like you want to be in
number two it on.she Amy's like yeah oh
yeah so I was like okay this must be
pretty good we got you know the Finals
MVP over at the movie you know talked
about he wants to pee and Uncle Joe to
so I was pretty fun
now there's two scenes where there's one
line in the movie I won't give the line
away but I think it's the line of the
movie and it's in last five minutes and
it's and you're involved in it yeah when
you first okay when you're reading the
script and you saw the line were you
comfortable with the line being in the
movie Oh Dan that wasn't in there I
asked I asked the director to put that
in there come on man is funny like come
on and so I loved the writer there and
also Charles so they put in I was you
know I was I was uh I was really happy
to have the name especially when I when
I saw the reaction now I did go see it
in Atlanta and everybody was like oh you
know
I asked for that to be in the movie this
has to do with Chris is a career at
Michigan the most famous his Michigan
career perhaps and then the baptism
scene is okay mom is your wife was
watching the movie you guys are in front
of us and so that's your daughter that
you're holding in the baptism scene but
explain explain what goes on in the
baptism scene as much as you want to
because I was curious what your wife is
thinkin and she's watching that okay
yeah well she was at the filming so she
was very happy even though you know it
kind of it so it's the same I'm allowed
to be a preacher and so it's I grew up
in a very small church just like the one
the one in the movie with people in my
family and maybe it was a church people
maybe so you know your kid you get the
play to turn arms you get to do all type
the Lord's was a lot of fun for being a
kid and so really what I did was trying
to channel all my own pastors a little
bit of my father and my father actually
was in that change so it was cool he was
like a deacon back there jumping up he's
jumping with Lisa Leslie and what Betty
Lou is she called and so I get to have a
baby and so I first called for twins and
I have twins and I was like I'm 16 so my
daughter
Elmarie she's in the in the scene with
me of course for people out there don't
kill me it's at all hosting time but
when we show it's my daughter
and so my wife I'm like you're the only
person that would shed a tear at least
know at funny movie could pop up on the
screen but she is really cool yeah yeah
hopefully everybody enjoyed what you
guys I thought then that's up you know
that Reggie actually didn't get you guys
take us out in law if he was really
gonna laugh out loud that there were
probably 15 moments that were laugh out
loud and you know the fact that you go
behind the back so you're in the
baptismal so here you have your baby
behind like your harlem globetrotter
with your baby beef with the bad
and I don't know I don't know who you
were channeling with your look
I thought you look sort of like a Jeff
Bridges and Billy Dee Williams like a
like a combo of Jeff Bridges with a
little al Sharpton with the with the
gray in a weird anything in house arpan
that's a heck of a combination okay can
you give give the audience can you do
your voice can you give us one line in
the voice oh okay I'm have to have some
static papers or so I don't mind it
works here we go literally at the point
okay oh man you got me on the spot all
right it was just something like good
morning
[Laughter]
I woke up a change my daughter's diaper
she had a nice little package for me it
was a gift
wait about two pounds Lord how did
something this small put so big your
wife they're looking at you like what
are you doing so the movies uncle Drew
and it opens nationwide on Friday and I
will say Kawhi Leonard if you don't know
all right
Kyrie Irving if you don't know it's
Kyrie he's that good in that role I
really thought I thought Kyrie was
legitimately great in that role yes yes
he was no you did a great job he knew
how not to overdo it and he carried the
movie I mean you know it was a great
opportunity for him you know letting us
be in it and and then working with us
but he set the tone in the place and
that's why I was good um you know I
think everybody really step their game
up and started off with Kyrie man it was
a lot of fun a lot of laughs Shaq's
great in there Reggie's great as well
there's a lot of a lot of fun a lot of
fun in there
my mom denied because she won't but uh
you know on the scene we're shocked his
Shack basically when he's in the
hospital I've watched that with my mom
and she literally almost fell trying not
to look at the screen so it Shaq is a
shack make sure he shows the people a
side of him that they've never seen
before
that was a shack crack is what that was
exactly what's that in the scripted
Shack was gonna he has his hospital gown
open in the back yeah I don't know if it
was in the script the real cool thing is
they really let us improv you know for
instance I know that they knew
basketball but I don't know if they do
basketball to the point of the average
fan and so you know I remember one time
we had to kind of fight for him to say
barbecued chicken they were like oh no
that doesn't make sense we're like no
you don't make sense you don't
understand then that's not saying all
this time and kids will get barbecue
chicken like their inside jokes inside
of basketball and you guys need to trust
this on since it's a basketball movie
and and they did that but not we were
not we were allowed to ad-lib ad-lib a
lot and that that's what was fun because
our guys were not not competing but um
like feeding off of each other able to
you know say okay that was a good joke
let me let me get my joking so fun
little improvising we're talking to a
Chris Webber former NBA all-star right
how's this all play out by the end of
the week with Kawhi LeBron Paul George
if you were guessing I'm confused now I
thought I knew what I was talking about
when I came into the show the other day
but you know and there's little things
that confuse you for instance new posted
something on Instagram and you know he's
the biggest Laker fan in the world Snoop
Dogg and he posted a picture of LeBron
putting on Chuck Taylors now I don't
know if that was a real picture but if
LeBron played in Chuck Taylors and yes
sir and commerce are owned by Nike but
if he played in Chuck Taylors the first
time of his life and Chuck Taylors a
terrible shoes to clinging that means
he's going to LA it Chuck Taylors is LA
that's LA all day you wear your Chuck so
if you know so that's that you know my
brother who thinks he's like
whose combined he thinks he has his
forces and everything once he showed me
this he says he's definitely going and
usually I like arguing with him all day
but I couldn't I couldn't say anything
on that conspiracy theory because it
seems it I thought he should go back to
clean but it does seem like he's in a
race between Cleveland on The Late Show
okay but who did they get Kawhi Leonard
or do you get Paul George in LA cuz I
don't know if you can get all three of
those guys yeah I always say all three
first cuz I don't know how just two
littles could be a super team and it was
just two of those guys I don't know
things get past Houston her own estate
so in my opinion has and I would
probably take why if I were the Braun to
switch defensively collide and you know
he doesn't need as many dribbles to
score as say as George he can go on the
post and again defensively he can change
the game so if I will upon it you know I
would hope it would be colaba when you
look at all of the options San Antonio
has is scary
first they can wait till make sure you
lose wait and see or I mean if they you
know not not to get my boy
Kyrie on the trading block but you know
the Spurs need a point guard desperately
I mean the Spurs the way their point
guard goes is the way that they go and
Tony Parker led the league in scoring in
the paint they put the office around and
they sped the pace up and pick your
Kyrie and the boss Nikolai and you still
have Kawhi Gordon Tatum Roscher for zero
stays the player he is that that could
be that could be scary so I'm always you
know when things are quiet I'm always
thinking about two people with Jerry
Westland never my brother calls them
pick Jerry where he tricks you and
you'll take you know he gets the traffic
you think he won and he has Kobe or you
go on the other side with Danny Ainge
both of those guys are working
feverishly right now and I wonder what
okay could you see Lonzo ball fees part
of this deal playing for Popovich in San
Antonio as his point guard I really like
Alonzo balls game if you look at his
numbers they're very similar to what
Jason Kidd the only thing is that we
just can't see it through all the smoke
and
his father and so I know if I'm San
Antonio I don't want that because we
don't play distraction games over
especially if we're gonna trade collide
we're not gonna leave you know we don't
want to go anybody going broke in the
locker room you know so the play of ball
is good enough to bring him over but I
don't know if the distraction or the
talking and how you know attract that we
are to his father saying you know all
this stuff I don't know how they would
like that in the locker room so as a
player yeah as everything else I don't
think by the way you left your hat and
very expensive sunglasses in the studio
so so we're gonna send those out to you
I think hopefully I get on meet Friday
minutes and while I'm grilling or about
yeah yeah all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
get that trigger girl to you I want to
see how good you are you gonna have
somebody grow for you Chris
no I have a personal battle with guys in
an NBA including Dennis Scott I'm
talking to you right now Dennis Collins
real comes
you already know what it is he and I
have a battle probably once a month of a
barbecue and what we do fake not top
stuff but I am a chef where you just
bring something over and you cook it so
I'm gonna be ready but I'm gonna need to
grill on this grill three or four times
to get you know to get it right to
season and then to make sure it works
for me the right way before I get it but
yeah I'll make sure I post some pictures
of them of the food maybe I'll start
with a brisket or some you know beef
ribs or something I don't know I'll
figure it out okay been on it's me gonna
chef why don't we have an NBA like
all-star competition with grilling now
first of all that would be a great idea
okay you wouldn't if you wouldn't be
able to do it because it'd be too many
guys trying to sign up every every every
guy I know we know Chris we could we
could do a March Madness
where we just we have we have a meet
Madness and then we just you know
elimination and people will vote on
who's the best grill are there
I like that not long as we know make
sure that the judges cuz you know every
guy's gonna say that you know the judges
just didn't take his because as long as
we could have you know affair we to hide
the food and relate it I'm definitely in
on a man but you know I'd have to come
here I'm I'm
I don't know you don't do that to
anybody but you
yeah I'm the master gorilla baby that's
me Wow hey congrats again on the movie
and thanks for joining us we'll talk
soon thank you Chris thanks a lot guys
that's Chris Weber NBA on TNT aims for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]